ce type est obsessionnel je pense que le
problème est plus psychologique voire
psychiatrique que judiciaire enfin il
est les deux d'ailleurs et là en fait on
traite rien et je pense d'ailleurs je
lance un peu un cri d'alarme parce que
tous les signaux sont en rouge pour
qu'il arrive un drame vraiment ce mec
n'a pas frein il est en prison il est
pas sorti de prison qu'il a déjà le
projet de Lucille il le dit au téléphone
un de ses amis la conversation est
écoutée
elle est rapportée je vous dis
franchement c'est fou cette affaire oui
en plus là les preuves elles sont là en
plus si la franchi la barrière du
virtuelle parce qu'il s'est pointé chez
elle il y a beaucoup de menaces qui
restent virtuelles là il est venu chez
elle bien sûr tu es chez elle il y a un
problème en France et c'est triste à
dire mais malheureusement tant qu'il
n'arrive pas à un drame c'est à dire une
agression extrêmement grave inspirable
on voulait la justice oui moi aussi j'en
veux aller juste dans ma vraie on ne
prend pas les menaces au sérieux et ça
les sable lui-même il dit dans ses notes
vocale de toute façon je sais que j'irai
pas 20 ans en placard et même les gens
qui voient ça se disent aujourd'hui bah
moi je peux menacer n'importe qui